OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER MONTH
TO MUSK FOR THE SERVICE.
WE HAVE MUCH MORE COMING OUT
FROM ALEX MARQUARDT.
FRED PLEITGEN HAS THE STORY.
>> Reporter: IT'S SO INTERESTING
TO SEE THE DEPLETED MISSILE
SUPPLIES THAT YOU JUST SHOWED.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'RE SHOWING
IS A LOT FEWER STRIKES HERE IN
KYIV AND IN OTHER PLACES AS
WELL.
AT THE SAME TIME ON THE FRONT
LINE, THE WAR IS STILL IN FULL
SWING.
NOW YOU HAVE THE RUSSIANS
GAINING SOME GROUND IN SOME
PLACES IN THE EAST WITH THE
UKRAINIANS MAKING A LOT OF
HEADWAY IN THE SOUTH, IN THE
AREA AROUND KHERSON, AND THAT
CLEARLY HAS A LOT OF PRO RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS VERY WORRIED.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE LEARNING.
EVEN AS RUSSIA HAS BEEN
BOMBARDING UKRAINE, UKRAINIAN
FORCES HAVE BEEN PUSHING
MOSCOW'S TROOPS BACK IN THE
SOUTH OF THE COUNTRY RAISING
THEIR FLAG IN NEWLY LIBERATED
AREAS LIKE IN THIS VILLAGE.
>> Translator: THE BOYS WORKED
FOR SIX, SEVEN MONTHS LIBERATING
OUR AREA.
THEY ARE RAISING THE FLAG OF THE
FREE AND UNITED UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: THE KHERSON REGION
IS ONE OF THE AREAS RECENTLY
ILLEGALLY ANNEXED.
UKRAINE'S ARMY IS INADVANCING SO
MUCH THAT RUSSIAN INSTALLED
OFFICIALS ARE ASKING FOR
CIVILIANS TO BE EVACUATED TO
RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
>> Translator: BECAUSE OF THIS,
THE KHERSON ADMINISTRATION HAS
DECIDED TO ORGANIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR KHERSON
FAMILIES TO TRAVEL TO OTHER
REGIONS OF RUSSIA FOR LEISURE
AND STUDY.
>> Reporter: KYIV ANNOUNCED THE
MOVE SAYING RUSSIA IS DEPORTING
PEOPLE RATHER THAN SAVING THEM.
UKRAINE HAS VOWED TO TAKE BACK
ALL THE TERRITORY RUSSIA HAS
SEIZED.
THE COUNTRY'S PRESIDENT SAID AT
A CELEBRATION FOR UKRAINE'S
DEFENDER'S DAY ON FRIDAY.
>> Translator: BY DEFEATING THIS
ENEMY, WE WILL RESPOND TO ALL
ENEMIES WHO ENCROACHED ON
UKRAINE, ON THOSE WHO LIVED, WHO
LIVE, AND WHO WILL LIVE ON OUR
LAND.
THIS WILL BE A VICTORY FOR ALL
OUR PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: BUT IN THE EAST, A
DIFFERENT STORY.
CIVILIANS FLEEING THE RUSSIAN
ADVANCE ON THE INDUSTRIAL TOWN
OF BAKMUT.
THESE PHOTOS SHOWING THE TROOPS
ON THE GROUND IN THE AREAS
SURROUNDING THE AREA.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA WAGNER FORCES
HAVE TAKEN A SMALL TOWN OUTSIDE
OF THE AT THE.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THERE WAS
NOT A SINGLE PERSON FROM OTHER
UNITS EXCEPT THE EMPLOYEES OF
WAGNER GROUP IN IVANGRAD.
WAGNER GROUP HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR
TACTICS.
THE GROUP'S MERCENARIES
COMMITTED MASSACRES IN LIBYA,
SUE DAM, MOZAMBIQUE AND THE
CENTRAL AFRICAN AREA.
HE'S SEEN RECRUITING CONVICTS
FROM PRISONS ADMITTING HE OWNS
WAGNER AND EVEN ATTENDING
FUNERALS OF ONE OF HIS FALLEN
FIGHTERS.
WAGGER UNITS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
PROMINENTLY INVOLVED IN RUSSIA'S
CAMPAIGN IN UKRAINE.
IT SEEMS THEY ARE NOW THE
SPEARHEAD OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
INVASION FORCE.
ERIN, YOU JUST SAW THAT
STATEMENT EMPHASIZING THAT IT
WAS ONLY WAGNER SOLDIERS OR
WAGNER TROOPS WHO ARE NEAR THAT
TOWN NEAR BAKMUT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE RIGHT NOW HE'S TRYING TO
ORCHESTRATE A POWER GRAB IN
MOSCOW, THAT HE'S TRYING TO HELP
POSSIBLY OUST THE DEFENSE
MINISTER OF RUSSIA AS OBVIOUSLY
RUSSIA'S CAMPAIGN IS GOING VERY
BADLY AND HIMSELF GRAB POWER
AMONG THOSE UNDER VLADIMIR
PUTIN, ERIN.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, FRED
PLEITGEN.
I WANT TO GO TO THE FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR, JOHN BRENNAN.
AUTHOR OF "UNDAUNTED, MY FIGHT
AGAINST ENEMIES AT HOME AND
ABROAD."
LET'S START WITH THE WAGNER
GROUP.
YOU HAVE THE POWER PLAY TRYING
TO CHALLENGE PUTIN'S DEFENSE
MINISTRY, DESCRIBED AS THE
SPEARHEAD OF THE RUSSIAN WAR
EFFORT.
WHAT DO YOU READ INTO THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK, ERIN, AS
REPORTED THE RUSSIANS HAVE DONE
SO POORLY ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
PUTIN IS LOOKING FOR NEW OPTIONS
AND TAPPING INTO THE WAGNER
GROUP, WHICH WAS NOTED, IS A
VERY BRUTAL ORGANIZATION,
PARAMILITARY.
THEY HAVE PROBABLY 8 TO 10,000
PARAMILITARY TROOPS.
I DO THINK THERE IS SOME
JOCKEYING AMONG THE VARIOUS
SENIOR LEADERS OF RUSSIA TRYING
TO TAKE COMMAND AND CONTROL AND
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE SO
POORLY.
JUST LAST WEEKEND HE APPOINTED
THE GENERAL OF SYRIA WHO REALLY
ENGAGED IN SOME BRUTAL TACTICS,
MASSIVE ATTACKS AND ASSAULTS IN
SYRIA.
SO I DO THINK AS PUTIN'S OPTIONS
ARE NARROWING AND AS THE RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE DOING SO POORLY ON
THE BATTLEFIELD, ESPECIALLY
KHERSON.
THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR SIX
MONTHS.
THE FACT THAT THEY WEREN'T ABLE
TO FORTIFY IT ENOUGH TO
WITHSTAND A UKRAINIAN ASSAULT IS
TELLING HOW INCOMPETENT THEY
ARE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE TO MEET WITH
MANY WHO KNOW PUTIN AND ARE
CLOSE TO PUTIN, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT A POWER GRAB, IT RAISES
BIGGER QUESTIONS.
FROM THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'VE MET
AND SEEN OPERATE AROUND PUTIN,
DO YOU THINK THAT WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE THEY WANT MORE ACTION OR
LESS ACTION THAT THERE COULD BE
A THREAT TO PUTIN?
>> I THINK PUTIN THINKS THIS IS
CONSEQUENTIAL TO HIS SURVIVAL.
THERE'S NO WAY HE WON'T BE ABLE
TO SURVIVE IF HE CAN'T CREDIBLY
CLAIM VICTORY.
WITH THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM,
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY
WORRIED.
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE SOVIET UNION MAY TRY TO MAKE
A MOVE AGAINST PUTIN.
HE DOES HAVE A MONOPOLY ON
POWER.
THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS, COUPLE
OF MONTHS I THINK ARE GOING TO
BE VERY DYNAMIC AND I THINK VERY
TELLING OF WHERE THIS CONFLICT
IS GOING.
>> I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
INCREDIBLE DIRE STRAITS, 86% OF
THE ESCANDER MISSILES ARE GONE.
THERE'S THE NUCLEAR ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM.
WE'RE SEEING THE VIDEO THAT I
SHOWED OF DRAFT OFFICERS WAITING
IN THE LOBBY OF AN APARTMENT
BUILDING TO GRAB MEN, WE'RE
HEARING FROM SOME OF THEM.
>> Translator: WE'VE GOT THIS [
BLEEP ] FOR TRAINING, WHO KNOWS
WHAT KIND OF HOUSE WE'RE AT.
[ BLEEP ] I TOLD YOU GUYS.
>> WHAT REGION?
THE LUHANSK REGION.
WE ARE MOBILIZED.
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE HERE AT ALL.
11 DAYS FROM WHEN WE WERE
DEPLOYED, HOW MANY TIMES DID YOU
SHOOT ALREADY?
ONCE.
THREE BULLET CARTRIDGES.
>> 11 DAYS FROM DRAFT TO FRONT
LINE.
ONE TRAINING, THREE BULLET TART
TRIJS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IN
THAT VIDEO.
THERE'S A LOT MORE WHERE THAT
CAME FROM.
DOES THAT SHOCK YOU?
>> NO.
PUTIN SAYS HE HAS DEPLOYED
16,000 OF THESE CONSCRIPTS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING A LOT OF
THEM WHO GO IN ARE GOING TO BE
CANNON FODDER.
THAT'S WHY I THINK HE'S OPTING
FOR OTHER GROUPS BECAUSE I THINK
THE LACK OF TRAINING, THE LACK
OF CAPABILITY OF THESE RUSSIAN
CIVILIAN